c'est la migration annuelle au Québec
mais surtout à Montréal où l'on compte
le plus de locataires
il y a ceux qui préfèrent déménager au
clair de lune ceux qui prennent quelques
libertés avec le stationnement ceux qui
se battent avec les escaliers et ceux
qui arpentent l'avenue du Mont-Royal sur
une montagne d'objets
mais jusqu'en 1974 c'est le premier mai
que l'on déménagé
[Musique]
ce qui compliquait la fin de l'année
scolaire pour les enfants
rien dans la nouvelle loi n’oblige à
terminer les baux le 30 juin et pourtant
tout le monde se met à déménager le 1er
juillet mais pas avec les mêmes
techniques
on peut affronter le déménagement à
mains nues
avec des sangles
ou avec un chariot d'épicerie est-ce
qu'il va loin ce monsieur
parce que faire appel à des déménageurs
ce n'est pas pour tout le monde j'ai une
de mes amis
et parfois on regrette d'avoir demandé à
ses amis
c'est que ce soit plus le premier
juillet justement à cause des coûts si
c'est l'enfer c'est une journée tout le
monde combien vous allez faire d'argent
une tradition qui pique la curiosité à
l'étranger et que la BBC est venue
documenter en Angleterre déménagé est
une grande menace et vous vous faites ça
collectivement se demande pourquoi
peut-être pour les anecdotes quand on
charge notre camion et qu'on arrive à
destination l'autre locataire est pas
sorti le logichanne la police arrive
[Musique]
pour la collation
pourquoi tu nous mettent dehors il va
perdre mes amis à l'école si tu as quand
même pas évident mais que la crise du
logement on va tellement le monde qui
qui en a pas et puis il y a les
coefficients de difficultés
supplémentaires comme déménager sur deux
roues
ou déménager en pleine pandémie un
souvenir pas si lointain on a très chaud
avec le masque
une chose est sûre aucune loi ne prévoit
de changer le balai du premier juillet
ah tu Prost Radio-Canada Montréal